okay for people joining this meeting
this is a kind of early exploratory
meeting in the project
of figuring out how to
uh integrate system modeler
with things like our entity framework
so maybe we should start off with a bit
of a reminder about um
system modeler and its integration right
now
um into the system
so let's start off with system model
examples which is a prototype example of
a
of a repository browser basically
at least that's the way i view it
and i think uh
let's see yarn is here right so
you you should be speaking up about
what's going on here right
so right now john are you here
hello
yeah sorry i had a problem unmuting
yeah
yes so
system of examples it's a
browser of
the
packages
containing
examples and components
that can be used in system modeler okay
so let me understand
relative to what all is available in
system modeler i mean if i go to the
system model home page
um
will i find a different set of um
uh
if if you if you go to
the system modeler uh
application you you will see a more
complete with this this is focused on
the examples things that you can run and
simulate directly if i go to the website
where would i go to find this stuff
you don't find it on the website if i
actually start up system modeler you're
saying yeah
i hope i have the most recent version
or we're recent enough it's
okay doesn't matter so so
basically it's uh on the left-hand side
here you see the class browser
that one contains uh all the examples
you find
but also other things like components
that you can use to create other
examples
um
let's just understand so i mean my
question is this
in you know we have a pretty good
pattern now for fun you know for the
function repository other kinds of
repositories
the question is
first question is is this a fit for that
okay
there's not a one-to-one match that's
for sure
no i understand that i understand that
but i mean to me there are
two primary here let me just um
uh save this
um so
i think that
we don't have anything
in
our
system that's primarily sort of building
blocks this is like think of lego okay
so they're kind of you can you can get a
ready-made
kit you know build this you know it's
exactly the pieces you need to build
that or you can get general person
general purpose lego pieces
of various kinds
okay so if you open if you open a class
browser there again i will in just a
second i'm just curious what the
from 2019 we had some notes here
okay
so this was horrible garbage i'm afraid
i'm sorry to say this was really
shocking
what was done there malta should be here
you know with but
in that case if we wanted to just
obviously we need to have him there yeah
obviously if he's the one well i thought
this was the future of it and i was
setting i was going to set this up but
you know with the appropriate sort of
you know trotian
compliment um
so we could could work through this okay
well fine but i don't know then this
meeting got scheduled anyway but so
we're here so
you drove this you you're driving i i
don't know what happened with this i i
don't have enough right now
because steven you had originally said
you wanted to
have proper pure non-entity work from
language representation of some things
like electric circuits
okay which is yet another branch
okay let's write down the branches that
we're dealing with okay
you know
directions here okay one is
repository eyes repository
eyes
class
we have a repository we call it the
library store right for system
we're going to look at that in just a
second okay
repository eyes
things
okay
repository okay that's one thing the
other thing is the entity
you know entity entity ising
repositorizing
entity izing
okay and the third thing is systemizing
okay that means actually making a
built-in just like i mean you know we've
been very successful now in chemistry
having actual built-in
you know structures
for things in chemistry and so on right
so the question is should we be doing
that for things like electric circuits
and other things which are you know very
generic very kind of widely used
uh
you know
concepts which also exist in system
modeler
right and maybe that was what this
meeting was supposed to be about but it
was mistitled so i didn't know
is is that what this was supposed to be
about michael
this is what you said you wanted to have
a meeting about
that's all what i can comment
okay all right well let's talk about
that for a minute okay
should i be getting malta
if you can yeah okay but but i i want to
see how this works first and then then
maybe that will help
okay so let's say i want to know about
electric circuits where do i go
so
first of all open modelica
okay
so i was just going to explain the sort
of the lego kit analog of what this is
okay so here you have
is like an analog kit so if you want to
build models that are analog electrical
models then these are the building
blocks that you will you know need or
want to do that
with these building blocks you can drag
and drop and connect to build
actually models
okay
you know you have to
well don't do that you
then you drag and then you're there like
that yeah
okay
right
what happens if i wanted to twist this
around to make it go down you have to to
put a
you click on the um
uh
did you see the connector up there in
the top bar go go up up up up up up up
there left left that one
i see okay and that one you need to to
use all the time to connect things so
you didn't actually connect
yeah you need to put that no well
why would you do that
so i move those apart
yeah and then i use the connector yes to
connect from here to there right correct
okay
now these wires they look like a single
wire but sometimes they're complicated
things
like you have vector wire wires you know
they
they transmit the physics between them
so in the case of a circuit they deal
with current and voltage
and you know if it was hydraulics it
would be pressure and flow
for instance so what we ship with is a
ready-made
set of libraries
if you look here if you browse if you if
you kind of close up we can see what
those weird that this is different
it's just weird
okay all right go ahead now so so even
under electrical you can see that there
are actually sub kits there okay so
digital electronics is different than
analog electronics i realized right i
was just looking at basic
yeah
and one thing that you see there is that
there is a set of examples okay there
are not that many but but you can see
under each such kit there is a set of
examples that actually do use them
but these are basically
yeah
and they make use of those components in
that kit but so these examples are not
on the web is that true
well there are on the web in the sense
that we've built web documentation and
no but i mean but wait a minute if i
find if i want to see out of four can i
see that on the web or not yeah
okay
where is it
so i go here you can uh the easiest is
probably search
yeah it should be under
reference.wolfram.com where we have it
so if our search worked it would have
found it
please report the failure of the search
then
okay
[Applause]
that's not the right thing this isn't
the right thing ignore me then can
somebody find me the actual url for out
of four please
this is pathetic i don't think this is
being searched
i think you made a mistake here i don't
think this is being searched
either that or it isn't true that these
things are on the web
well there there is a system modeler
section it doesn't look like it's being
searched
are you serious
is this
a spell
a spell correct notification there
no that's not the other one wasn't
okay so this looks like kind of old a
bit old right
but it is here it is here so it'll be
refreshed and regenerated as we build
the documentation
for the 13-0 release is this click to
copy
no that's i think that's uh yeah yes to
watch it
the the below the example below is click
to
copy that
blue for some bizarre reason
okay
all right so
and
now in the new version when you do
system modeler there will be a link to
this collection of exam documentation
what do you mean in in a raft here
no
if you go to the if you go to the page
the system model page no no i understand
it but are you like import doesn't have
no but what we need to make sure of is
that we're actually using the whole raft
mechanism right here so does this hold
on
um
okay so that is some kind of ranked list
here correct that looks very weird
yeah so that's wrong so get it right
okay so that's another thing for your
list
who who here is making the list
i don't know who's making the list but
i'm making notes
that's fine
okay get the notes we can connect
okay that's just wrong
yes okay so that two user assistants
that's that's the you know that's the
right place
um
okay so that's that okay so now if you
look at the source
to the system model okay
we don't have 13-0 built documentation
yet right now i get it
yeah
but i'm just commenting on what should
happen here so i mean in a perfect world
just like we have you know when you say
rgb color
and
there's nothing there
why is there nothing that does oh no i
know what the problem is
choose color
see that
that is essentially a
um
you know that's an enhanced
autocomplete
and what we want to work towards is
having something like that
for
that is essentially a a repository
browser
what i'm saying makes sense
okay so
what that relies on
is
being able to take this you
you know what you've got here is our
only example right now of a repository
browser i don't particularly like this
one but we don't have any other
repository browsers right we intend to
have a function repository repository
browser
do you see what i'm saying yeah
and we should then standardize how the
repository browser works
but one of the things which i wanted to
address for just a couple of minutes
here before we turn to to to well to
we're going to return to all these
different pieces okay
so first question is
does it make any sense
to
have
resource system resource objects
associated with each of your
items here
do you see what i'm saying
in in your
in
this right
we could have it be the case that every
one of these a u line whatever a u line
is
what what did that do
when i double click that is that
bringing me up a u line as as my only
yeah
yeah so it's open up that that
particular look at all the tabs
yeah look at all the tabs up there i see
okay okay fine
okay and so this has many parameters
correct
um
right
okay
gosh i hate the fact that we haven't
been able to get proper integration for
this stuff
i really hate it
look at this thing
well whatever i mean i could you know
this is a very nice interface very nice
interface just a shame that we we have
such incompatibility
um
and maybe maybe there's nothing to do
about it maybe it's hopeless
we've decided to not build deep
compatibility i would consume
we would
so it leverages
we are part we have founded and we are
part of a community developing a
language called modelica for this
right yeah and
so we didn't develop another language
that's incompatible with all that
but what we do have
is a way
to
to to not sort of um
you know in in
in the woman i have no idea what any of
this is i mean you know as far as
modeling this is modality garbage yeah
right i mean this is this is just like a
completely separate thing
but it's
but but in terms of usability so you can
do
you can programmatically build you can
interactively build this model using
this product right you can
programmatically build them using the
wolfram language
you can do analysis and design work in
the wolfram language because this
primarily if you use this product as is
it's primarily meant to be a modeling
framework what if i have a piece of
woven language code and i want it to run
inside inside when you can't
no so that's that's not possible but
that's a future extension
but the wolfram language code usually we
need to sort of segment it out because
wolfram language code is usually pretty
slow compared to the simulation code
you know well but that won't be true
with compiled code
well i mean at the different things you
can build
there's some it's okay that some things
are slow like if you if you run an
imaging loop you know let's say that you
build a cyber yeah i understand that i
understand that but i'm i'm saying if i
want to actually build something okay so
look look
what we have to decide you know maybe we
decide we're just not going to try and
integrate these things
right
but you know what i think we need okay
the
what was i guess the original purpose of
this meeting is the possibility that we
should build into our language
you know the capability to do things
like electric circuits you know by the
time we're building elaborate you know
heat transfer pde stuff why are we not
building basic ode
now clearly system model has much more
sophisticated ode models but the
question is should we have something
where we have a function called resistor
you know or resistor model or something
like this where we literally have
something just like we have for pdes
we have this elaborate
system
for representing pde modeling why are we
not doing that for these basic uh basic
things like this
yeah
but
it's a s i mean
you know we're clearly not the the
the problem is we've already got deep
coverage with gyrators and you know
whatever cc
yeah right we have deep coverage we're
not gonna it makes no sense we're not
gonna repeat that coverage right
but
it also
doesn't make sense that if i just want
to put together a simple rlc circuit
as sort of a proxy for
i don't know some model of a of a tree
or something right that i'm going into
this
diving into this weird other language
and doing all those kinds of things
it doesn't make any sense
just like it wouldn't make sense
if you know if suddenly when we were
going to use i don't know sparse arrays
we suddenly have to dive into some
completely different world with 75
options for everything
right
the question is is there a piece of this
that is you know like basic electric
circuits
basic mechanics
that is sufficiently generic but then
you're talking about i mean so
john sends something out there you can
connect components but it's still a bit
weird it's it's kind of a
if you click on what john sent out in
chat
yeah
it's so you can still do it okay but i
find that it's it's a bit
you know look at that
well i mean so let's make an electric
circuit
yes this is grotesque i mean this is
utterly grotesque right you know it's
got it's got dots for you know
underscores and all kinds of things
completely incompatible concepts
right but then what you're talking about
is us basically designing our own base
language instead of in place yes that's
correct that is correct i'm talking
about either that or potentially making
a wrapper around this that turns it into
something but again we don't need
you know and i'm not sure how to how to
set this up but you know the depth
of
coverage here
is
important for engineering
irrelevant
for generic modeling
am i making sense
in other words what is generic modeling
just
i mean somebody who is
i don't know they're making a model of
some feature of a pandemic and they want
to use the analogy of an rlc circuit
okay and they want something which
essentially is going to give them just
like
in
uh
you know
in the pde modeling world
i don't know whether the you know the
fact that we have acoustic pde models
right
presumably those will be used by people
doing acoustics i'm not sure i don't
think it would be horrifying for
somebody to say you know i'm gonna well
you know i'm going to use the acoustics
model to model some feature of
perturbations in the early universe
even though there wasn't anybody with an
ear in the early universe if you get
what i'm saying but it happens to be the
same equations
so yeah so in a sense there are two
additional libraries here that that do
sort of that system dynamics library
where you have an abstraction where if
you look at at the
here the the capacitor for instance that
she has something sort of a storage a
volume or something could be
representing different things
so there are things where you have that
more generic uh representation where
we're not saying that this is a capacity
just say this is something that stores
something
right but i mean so
to me
the difference is
you might have a capacitor there that is
a
such and such you know uh
sku capacitor from such and such vendor
with these characteristics
and that's what
this product is about i think that there
is about
i can't remember now but i think it's on
the order of between five and seven
seven thousand objects to introduce
um
yeah right with this which we don't want
right which we don't want right that's
that's that's the whole point what i'm
saying is
you know if you included every item in
oh i forget that you know in in these
these big uh catalogs
you know of components but but these are
not so the other thing that you're
talking about which is one level up from
this like an electrical motor that's
something that's built from a bunch of
this from several of these kits
basically i i know okay no and there's a
whole world of those
i'm wearing well aware of that and this
is not intended to be like a catalog of
electrical motors
to terms although in principle somebody
could have a metallica specification of
those things which they could feed into
the system yeah and actually it's useful
for other reasons to want to have such a
thing like if you buy a product can i
also get a model of it sure
right now it's obviously you know and
maybe way to sell a product is to to to
give you the simulation model so you can
play with it and design it in i i
understand that that's that all makes
sense right and that's why you know lots
of companies that sell components have
somewhat computable you know yeah
cardinals somewhat computable spec
sheets et cetera et cetera et cetera
okay so
one question that that exists here is
there is a level of engineering detail
that you have here
that level of engineering detail is
utterly irrelevant to the person who's
learning about rlc circuits it's utterly
irrelevant to the person who is using an
rlc circuit as an analog
for
you know something about some random you
know piece of epidemiology am i making
sense they don't care what the breakdown
voltage is for that capacit you know for
a you know a a cj 75 capacitor or
something right
but the engineer who's designing the
system modeler does care about that
so the question is is there a level of
idealization that we can because you
know the thing that doesn't make sense
to me is that we have things like
detailed acoustic pde models and we
don't have rlc circuits
i tend to i tend to agree with you
um
but i don't think that has to do with
entities though i just it may not it may
not i'm just i'm look okay let me let me
let me again i'm just trying to put
pieces together here so you know system
modeler is a deep engineering level
coverage of things true but we are also
building shallow learning versions of it
like our
well great but then then the question is
could those be into could we take
what is being done there
and simply
transport it into waltham language
and if so what is the correct transport
mechanism because it isn't
things with little dots on them well i
agree with you i just i completely agree
with that but
why don't but it's not it's easy to
agree with it's it's harder to find the
solution now
work on it yeah
what i want to survey is
what are the frameworks that we have in
the language and in system modeler that
might connect
okay
that that was what i was that was kind
of what i was what i was looking for
here and so i think there are these so
if you if you want to think about sort
of what we modeled what we provide in
the wolfram language interface now is
basically that connectivity interface so
you can see a component out there it has
various ports those are just um
blue squares here they're ports yep so
what what can connect the walls and in
the language take this one here could i
take this particular one
this is how do i copy how do i copy the
name of this
uline
i think you can just
paste it into language okay yeah just
paste it
paste paste okay all right so i just say
system model
model and then i paste that name
is that correct well you could do that
but you could also have just pasted it i
think it would have just worked
yeah but uh yeah it just space now that
just copies the string so this was the
right thing to do and now now that just
shows the diagram of it and okay so now
how do i get all this stuff here how do
i get this information here
uh
that's asking for the properties that it
has yeah right so how do i do that
um
system model and
what the heck
why did that not work
what the heck is this what build are you
in
i don't know some build that isn't
working very well clearly yeah
let me um
let me just quit this and i'm going to
restart with a different build
i think this build is all of two days
old
so
go to that home page okay so then you
know system model that and then you can
have you can ask for properties okay
let's go there hold on one second
um
i mean i would like to make a meta
comment here i am pretty sure that with
a bit of cleverness we can leverage a
huge amount of work that's been done in
system modeler to make it really rather
easy you know it's going to be some
framework building to make this bridge
but it isn't a rewrite everything story
am i making sense
um yeah
yeah impossible to somehow convert
automatically in the back end convert
some of this into a demonstration
uh if we have the code that would be
generated on system modeler i don't know
how that works exactly but if we
converted who's speaking
then you can expose it in the entity
framework and i'm pasting into the chat
something you could try now to like
sort of simulate a basic
um electrical circuit we could just
extend the coverage somehow so first of
all it it works
you know in a demonstration right now
because
you mean
no but this is what the heck is this
this is an actual demonstration right
yes
wow i wonder how this works no idea how
this works but in any case okay but that
that's
that's just making the point that the
demonstrations project
which we haven't mentioned up here as
part of our um
is an is a place where we have an
entity-based representation
of
okay so this is a demonstration as an
entity
that makes sense to you guys
oh you decided to suck all the
demonstrations in
yes
okay fine well i sucked them in as
paclets once upon a time so yeah it's
easy to do
i i understand but the whole point roger
is we're trying to figure out how do we
take what's here
and make the right kinds of things
exposed in the language okay right but
but but but you
okay there's a thing that you have to
understand that a lot of components
can't be simulated
a resistor can't be simulated without
connecting it to a lot of other stuff
yeah
no i understand that i understand that
so i'm i'm just like if you say you know
can you solve the equation x squared
no it's going to be x squared plus x
equals something or other that's an
equation you can solve the pure monomial
x squared is just a disembodied creature
sitting there
well yeah
right it's the same type of thing so
okay so here
if i say
so if i take this thing here and i say
properties
wow why did this why is this taking so
long isn't this wooden this shouldn't
just give a list of properties oh it did
yeah the first time it loads the whole
system a little machinery so that's why
it took time
okay
probably need to because every every
single system model has the same
properties doesn't it
yes
okay so then you have parameter names
and parameter values okay okay
right so parameter
name for instance yeah
okay which are quite grotesque
yes those are the syst those are the
modelica names just like yes
let's give an analogy here okay let's go
to analogy
in
in the entity world
we have plenty of grotesque okay so what
do we do in the entity world for the
stuff
okay so michael or somebody can you give
an example of something where the actual
name of an entity is somewhat grotesque
let's try
okay let's try alan turing okay there he
is as an entity but what actually is
that
okay well it's got a bunch of crud in it
there you see what i'm saying
because we need that for disambiguation
blah blah blah
so as an entity name the stuff you have
here is absolutely hunky-dory there's no
problem but there's an entity name
what's an entity name
what is it is this standard name how do
you think is programmatically referred
to not what you look at
i see
like
so this is for you guys in the entity
world you you think of these things all
the time like an entity name yes that's
right so these so this is like a key
like in a database no no no not really
like a summary books is a a combination
of this summary books looks totally
different than what's inside
right but the point for rogers purposes
is what i'm saying is the names you have
here you don't have to touch you don't
have to do anything with these names
they're fine
as enter these standard names
do you see what i'm saying
so i mean
now the next question is does it have
so so now
does this have a human readable name
what is this there is there a parameter
description somewhere here
because there is over here there's a
parameter description right is there not
or what is there
yeah
um what is that where where is that john
was where
so on
you have a description for each
paragraph so each parameter has a value
it has a unit it has a right so that
would be in our world that would be the
common name okay this is the standard
name this allen turing little rub is is
the standard name okay it's the unique
identifier
right
but if i say
of um
a common name of line five or just let's
put this thing in there right common
name of this
then i will simply get the string alan
turing
okay and that common name is what's
painted inside this yellow box
does that make sense
so
how many keys are i mean that key that
alan turing 2f4 s8
how many things does that look up
that's a key to everything
yeah i mean there's millions of things
that this
this is one of our entities of which
there are many million
right but but what i meant is how many
more how many property properties you
call them right yeah yeah so we can we
can ask for alan turing we can say what
are the properties of alan turing
somewhere between 10 and a thousand
depending on the domain
right so there's where the properties
are now notice that these properties
again
are yellow boxes here now if we take
that object and we say what is it right
the input form of that is
that an energy property thing which in
that case is fairly human readable but
it might not be so those are not
entities they're entity properties that
is correct
so that's another thing that you have
that is correct do you have more things
than entities in it there are a few
other things yes but those are those are
the principal things
so
so the keys you call entity properties
that is correct okay
we would have liked to call them
properties that hadn't been
you know stolen
by the graf system at some point well if
attributes hadn't been stolen for
something completely useless
right
okay in any case
we are where we are um and we have a
similar system for wiki data we should
say
yes that's worth should we show a piece
of that is that relevant because because
what i think is that there's a way to
move this i'm still michael i'm still
going to want i mean if it's just about
sort of getting this
sort of entities
then i still want to sort of have
regular meetings discussions this is
what i was planning to set up as soon as
we're out of this release cycle
okay well fine but but i'm just going to
get i'm trying to make the the general
outline because i think this is going to
work very nicely i think it's going to
be rather easy actually
well it's incomp well okay but you don't
care
what i actually think like
the palm middle names that you put out
where you say they are okay
but they are kind of not things i feel
like at the level of entity there are
nearly more things at the level of say
physical
[Music]
quantity variable yes it also has a
couple properties like uh
dimensions and related things but
because they're all different like
everything that has kind of parameters
like one two three four
is frequently i feel like not an entity
it's something else parameter
parametrized by some other domain
i'm not quite sure i understand that
like a time series or a quantity series
something like this
like look at
uh the result of the parameter names
output that you have there rc length n i
don't think they should become entities
that would be i feel like no that's okay
there should be something like entities
not probably entities themselves
and i don't know i mean michael when we
do
uh
qualified entities entity instances
what are the names of the qualifiers in
entity instances
let me let me let me
okay
for
rogers
you know an entity instance
is something like three grams of sodium
or something yeah
okay
so in this case here
well here's a good example of an entity
instance right
that feels i mean i don't think these
are very beautiful yet
but that feels very much like your
qualified
version your parametrized version of
your
you know whatever it is uline object
do you see what i'm saying
roger and others maybe yeah
okay this is saying a half taurus is the
general thing
and it has these parameter values
again i'm not totally thrilled with all
aspects of how this works but that's
this would be you have a u-line entity
and it has these parameter values
because a half taurus on its own
is we don't know i mean there are there
are purposes for which it's useful to
have the concept of the half taurus
entity independent of
its specific parameter values
do you get what i'm saying
and i can imagine that
in in the case of you know system part
of part of what i've never gotten really
is like why would you want them as
entities i mean why do all this
why do you want them as entities
so they fit into the rest of the system
why why would why do they fit more when
they're entities because we have tons of
of
functions that do things like entity
classes entity lists
properties so you want to look
functionality of
the lookup the searching functionality
from from the entity world to work is
that yeah among other things yeah the
main benefit you want but but there are
also things like that there aren't just
12 of them where there are hundreds of
thousands like groups or something like
this
where you can't
either remember or easily
programmatically build the names for
things not not
right but where look the point is my
point i'm trying i'm challenging you a
little bit i'm not hostile or anything
i'm just challenging you it's like what
do i get back if i make them entities do
i get anything back yes yes what you're
gonna get i just okay what you're gonna
get back is the fact that instead of
all of us complaining every time we see
this stuff in the system we say that
looks like garbage
right
all of this stuff looks kind of ugly and
it looks like it's some piece of
object-oriented you know something
rather wheeled in et cetera et cetera et
cetera
i mean roger has a certain point like
what exactly
entity versus
other
headers gif is under discussion that's
under discussion i agree i'm saying an
entity-like thing i'm saying we learn
from the entity framework what to do
because we've already worked this out
for many aspects so you know look the
two frameworks that i think are
interesting to look at for this are the
chemistry framework and the entity
framework okay maybe three chemistry
entity and pde framework those are all
three
sort of pseudo models for what we're
talking about here
now the real cause of wiki is not
uninteresting
data and uh
partially even even if it's not too big
formula data
it's another big collection it doesn't
have its own header wrapped around but
it's something that has computational
data
okay all right well yeah let's look at
that okay so wikidata
what's an example that we can show here
i mean this is this is something which
is
very
um
you know this is a jungle
the you know the wikidata world is a
jungle but we are able to
you know we have good programmatic ways
to interact with that jungle
are making sense
and so insofar as modelica as a jungle
which i don't think it is nearly as much
of a jungle i think modelica is much
more similar in character to one of our
either repositories or possibly entity
stores
i'm not sure which yet
making sense okay if you're more
flexible about it then i'm you know i
will still sort of set up this thing to
meet with michael or someone he wants
yeah i know but but we need to we need
to know what the target is because i
think okay so michael is saying there's
also wiki data what was the other model
that michael mentioned omela data is a
certain
in a certain sense related okay so let's
look at formula let's see that that is
formula data there
um
because it's probably my bad because i
think of entities as stamp collecting a
bit you know it's like lots of stamps
you know i just need to sort them into
bins yeah but there are certain things
like like minerals there isn't there
isn't a theory until today
i see yeah the temp collecting is the
only choice to right i mean take care of
this domain yeah you are correct the
world is full of stamps
right cities are stamps you know it's
all there's a chemical model building is
a bit more principled
you know
i think we go far below quantum field
theory now but that's a different story
but
you know potentiometer is a stamp
well
well okay but
then then special functions are stamps
too
they are somewhat yes yes they are
that's the thing that you're not
understanding roger is that
okay
you think an entity is just a blob where
you deliver it and there's nothing you
can do with it that is completely
incorrect well i don't think that
there's much you can do with it
yeah but what does that mean i mean if i
have look for example no no it's a great
handle okay no no look if i have the
entity in new york city right what can i
compute about that i could say geo
position of new york city i could say
uh local time in new york city right so
we're gradually enhancing the kinds of
things that interact with this
right so we're computing things where
the entity it's just like let me give
you two other examples okay the number
75
right what can you do with the number 75
you might say it's just a stamp just
sits out there it's the number 75 well
the fact is we've got a thousand
functions that probably do something
interesting with the number 75
because as you say it's a it's an anchor
it's a it's a handle right to this thing
which is the number 75. so i'll give you
another example let's try
you know the molecule um and by the way
this is kind of interesting because i'm
now specifying that molecule
that just gave me an idea so let's say
that we build these
anchors entities whatever we want to
call them
we could probably augment what we know
from system modeler with what we
uh can add to
from the the wolfram alpha team by
curating and adding more data yeah
yes
yes yes roger that's what i've been
saying for like five years yes
yes and what we would be able to do you
know
i mean the the thing is that system
modeler and system modeling is kind of
you it doesn't have a story about the
history of the resistor
like who invented it and [ __ ] like that
it doesn't know it doesn't even care
it's very utility oriented that's
correct but you can attach so you know
this molecule i don't know anything
about but
i just want to point out this is another
kind of thing so i might say you know
molecule plot 3d or something here i
might ask for some you know some other
property of this molecule right this is
a this is a parametrized thing this is
not
as such an entity okay
this is a a molecule i could give
molecule an entity here like you know
heptane or something
that that's giving it an
entity but the thing you get out
is
a um
what am i trying to say
i'm just showing you this as an example
of a of yet another kind of framework
that we have where yes i mean the the
key point
if entities were just look ups
it wouldn't be as interesting what makes
entities really interesting
is that they are things that you can
compute with
right i could say
new york city boston i could say geo
distance between them
now what is the analog of that for a
potentiometer
i'm not sure because as you say
the disembodied thing i mean there is a
certain amount that can be done with the
sort of the zero argument version of it
the disembodied potentiometer you could
ask for example what does it i don't
know you could ask what units of
something or other does it produce i
don't know exactly what you'd ask what
might you ask of a potentiometer on its
own
other than you you could ask i mean if i
say
uh you know
uh gadolinium
discoverer
okay so there that is an entity property
that will tell us
the
as another entity the discover of
gadolinium
so what would what could you imagine
doing
if we think about potentiometer as such
rather than that particular one that
you're looking at of course it's one
thing you could ask which type of
potentiometer it is
and in which systems it's used if we
uh yeah okay fair enough i mean you
could say you could ask a question like
what of what other things that we have
is that a component
yeah we which we sort of that that's the
thing we do
in the system of a product today we
always show in where it's used but yes
but we could do it more general here and
perhaps fit it into
suppose there is a corresponding model
for that in the
pde
uh
part of from oliver has a potentiometer
example perhaps who knows then then then
we should be able to link to that of
course and see
details of this zack on our live stream
is pointing out this example let's take
a look at this so that's yeah that's a
really good example thank you for that
example michael you should have brought
up this example the physical maybe you
did and i wasn't paying attention
because it's so near to the toes example
you had that's why i thought it was
covered but i think it's more
interesting look at this example this is
a double pendulum okay so this is
incredibly close to what you're doing
over here
no but this is a this is a ready-made
example it's not a component
okay
don't worry so much about this
components thing i don't think that's
going to be a big issue it's just like
the the number 75 is oh i see what
you're saying the parameters for it yeah
the parameterization so i don't even
know what these parameters are what are
these oh these what's the description of
them these are just
then you see it a little bit more in
context right but but actually that's
another kind of object which is a
quantity variable which we didn't
discuss which which is relevant to these
guys because that that's probably what
these should be it's quantity varying
that's what i said earlier it should be
well i wasn't paying attention i'm sorry
okay here it is okay so this is
right that's exactly what it should be
right do you see what this is this is a
named
you know this has a name it has a it has
a it has a visible name here
and but it has
um
it is it is of that physical quantity
type now presumably over here you know
you have units here
i doubt you've curated what physical
quantity type but you have curated what
units it is is that correct guys
john can you say something about that
what do you mean curated what units
look look look here okay
v
is a physical quantity it's named v okay
you have a physical quantity named
lowercase r here okay
in this case
we know that v
is a physical quantity
it has an entity there is an entity
which is
physical quantity right is that what
it's called physical quantity physical
quantity
electric potential
okay
now
it has units of volts
but
there are other things with units of
volts which are other physical
quantities
do you see what i'm saying
yeah
okay so what i'm saying is what you've
got over here
is curation at the level of units but
probably not curation at the level of
physical quantities
yeah right although it's not that big a
deal but but you know there is a generic
physical quantity michael can speak to
this because he's a big expert on all
this stuff
of there is a presumably a generic
physical quantity that goes with the
given unit designation
it goes on in the other direction right
given given if concrete physical
quantity it has a canonical unit
but you don't have for a unit generic
because it depends on unit systems and
other things okay so resistance per
meter
we would have a notion of a physical
quantity which is resistance per meter
we would have resistivity we would have
as the canonical unit
okay all right okay so fine so this the
point is this is a physical quantity a
resistivity physical quantity whose
which is a quantity variable with name r
and some value here and so this object
this uline object
would be very much like this you know it
might be called system component
you know uline and then it would have an
association
that um
you know is it is essentially exactly
this this thing here right
that makes sense
um the uh
um
i mean that just crossing i had long
discussions about this one might even
think when introducing a new symbol that
connects uh like you've write in so many
textbooks v equals three volt to unite
this in one blob
rather than through a generic rule
i see
i didn't quite understand that so so
you're saying
well you have a physical quantity
named v that has the values revolt
i see what you're saying you're not
gonna
plop this together with one new head
that makes some sense
right i see so a valued i mean it's
basically a valued
variable yes exactly
um
okay but but so i want to come back over
here so i mean the mapping between this
construct
and
what we're currently having as physical
physical system entities seems fairly
fairly fairly good
okay now the next question the big
question is so what do you do with this
right because in the system model world
these are you know things that get
connected together
right yeah
and in
and they are primarily connected if i'm
not mistaken in graphs is that true
yes
there's a textual form as well
what does the textual form look like
it's the modelica language and you can
see it if you click on that text thing
up there
well
there's like
like a paper to the left like it looks
like a piece of paper like a piece of
text up there yeah that one and this one
doesn't have any connections of course
because this is just equations
where is the actual okay let's find
something that has connections let's go
to an electric motor or something where
would we go do an example
yeah
a chewer circuit that's something that's
a nice differential equation you type
thing sure
okay
and there you see the part that says
connect
and then it says okay so those are
essentially graph engines yes
and also you can see the connections
between ports like the ln port is
connected to the
r0p port but presumably that
there could be multiple copies so there
are multiple resistors each with a such
and such port
and so what you really need to be saying
is you know okay so this is
different names so yes absolutely yeah
the instances they're different
instances
right so the system specification would
be very much like a graph
which has you know nodes and and edges
important right
yes
if you look at the right hand side of
the of system mode there's a component
browser and i think that to to
a cleaned version of that is sort of
what you're looking for
so if you if you go now to the if you
keep here in the right most right hand
side you see that yeah there
where you can expand the difference it
says okay the c2 then consists of blah
blah blah but it goes into all those
details that you talked about so it's
it's finding the right abstraction level
to watch what level of details are we
interested to sort of drill down here
which parts of these are we
interested to represent
um
my gut feeling tells me that it's the
things
that have
icons
to them those are the things that we are
interested in so for instance the
uh yeah the i and the va well they are
variables we might be interested in
those anyways but yeah i think this is
that view shows how it's sort of built
up
in a in a graph and and this is the one
you sort of want to
right but so so i mean
the question would be
if
okay so basically what
the the setup is it's components and
connections roughly is what you're
describing here yeah
right and the connections require it
requires ports
whereas a node right now you just an
edge is just right right now
currently
and and this is something we need to fix
for other purposes currently an edge
is just
you know node goes to node
right
but what it really should be but it
should be and we need this for many
other purposes it should be
uh essentially
you know
node
dot
dot port goes to node
no dot to node port right yeah and and
and also here
like these ports are it's important to
so you can't if you have a resistor of
course you can't connect that to a mass
there's so so that
that node between them is impossible to
to make in them well i'm sorry what are
you talking about
so we know something about
these um edges
so there are different edges there's a
there's a collection of different edges
or connections just as there are
collections well right
that's like unit agreement i mean yes
yeah yeah exactly it's exactly that
stephen
right it's a unit agreement okay so for
an electrical motor you can't connect
the torque
to
an electrical circuit but the output
which is you know the input which is
electrical could come from an electrical
circuit the output which is torque can
collect to some mechanical system no i i
understand but that but that's analogous
to things we have not had this issue too
badly i mean this question about
you know unit incompatibility
is something for whatever reason maybe
michael can comment on this
it's not a front and center in your face
issue typically in other words you write
a formula it has incompatible units we
say it has incompatible units you fix it
life goes on in other words it's not
something which holds one up a lot i
don't think
for these big systems it's it's kind of
a safety
um
thing that you can't connect you know
they're just icons right who knows what
you're connecting i understand i mean
we're not trying to solve okay look the
question is
okay the thing i'm trying to understand
is i think i think we're getting some
sense
that
of roughly what the representation of
the system model world i mean to me
there are there are several targets okay
one is there's a huge amount of curation
that's already happened in system
modeler which could be exposed in things
like wolf alpha which is of high
interest there for engineering students
and professionals and so on and it kind
of leads them you know if if i say an
overvoltage protector or something
right now wolf and alpha wouldn't know
anything about that but there's probably
a bunch of information that is
immediately available from what's
already been done in system modeler and
exposing that is also a way to lead
people into system modeler et cetera et
cetera et cetera right but just to
understand and you've heard me say this
every time we meet
those examples are not encyclopedic or
complete or anything like that i know
they're just i know that but i know that
i mean i'm curious in the world of
modelica has somebody made a more
complete do we have the most complete
collection of things that exists
beyond nobody has such a collection in
that sense
um
i would say
okay but i mean but fine but the
libraries all the libraries in
themselves are
individual collections of different
things but there's
there's not the real are there a bunch
of vendors who've produced
large delica libraries for things yes
there are there are a bunch of vendors
and there's a bunch of open source
right i mean but i mean component
manufacturers for example
i think we're in the beginning stages of
that yeah kind of what happened in the
cad industry
that that vendors are starting to
provide simulation models and it's
industry by industry so like the pump
industry might be behind
the circuit industry
yeah
and and some in many times what they
want when they have their model that
developed internally they don't want you
to have access to all the details so
then they distribute that in their
in something called a functional mock-up
unit which is a
let's say
essentially a binary of some kind would
yes essentially binary of it
okay okay fine i understand well that
makes sense but but okay so look i mean
the things that we get you know we've
got
three parts to this whole story we've
got system model itself and there's the
question of what can you know warfarin
language
give back to system modeler as in for
example programmatically created
designs you know with some i don't know
what you know fancy genetic algorithm
pro you know
programmatically created design that is
then exported to system modeler
i thought just some others more
interested in data for materials or
something like that
your data for sure of different kinds um
yeah right so you guys can use that
yes and we can use that and we can use
this is there a mechanism if if i made a
wolfram language representation of this
circuit i don't even know that it would
be and i think that's what we're
discussing here if i could make that and
i run it through my genetic algorithm
that uses some fancy machine learning
thing that uses blah blah blah blah blah
in the language and then i want to
export that to system modeler how would
i do that
how would i even conceptually do it it's
in the making
okay no no no i mean i mean that works
now
just not i mean so that those
that works now that works since we
introduced it it worked 10 years ago in
the wsm link
but it works now with the system model
and so on functionality yeah but i
thought
if he had the machine learning algorithm
and wanted to use it
that was what i uh no no no no no no no
okay no okay got you
okay so this is your version of the
double pendulum and so your version okay
that's beautiful we don't you know in in
the entity we don't i suspect how do we
have a diagram of it here
maybe we do
make property association
and you see what's still
lots of stuff but no diagram okay right
okay fine but but um you know but but
somewhere inside system model you will
be able to generate equations just like
this
yes
okay well not just like but in principle
yes
well no but but what you'll have is is
you'll have your name variables
yeah
so
another thing what another thing to
remember okay is that you you could do
exactly what you did here if you
manually curate the equations you could
type in the equations what system
modeler does is to use not ods but dias
because i understand
then then you have this flexibility of
connecting everything to everything i
get it right which is highly interesting
and i i mean that
right
i got it and and so
here
in this case if i were to ask for
you know
for example is it equation what is it
called
modeling
equations uh if i remember i i i i know
no it's not that it's not it's not it's
definitely not and by the way you need
an automatic
you failed to have an auto complete
there and you should have had an
autocomplete there can you take notes
notes for that yep let's there's a lot
of fit and finish things that we want to
do too okay
okay but but
where is the equations then here uh
[Music]
see wouldn't it be nice if you had
linguistics where you could type in you
know double pendulum equations and it
would just because i bet if i type in i
i i find the initial equations but i'm
blind for the equations
[Laughter]
where are they but you see look i mean
it's there
double pendulum equations for example
i bet i will get
that's a bit weird
what is that
i don't know what that is this gave the
solution other than the equation of
movement
but you should be able to get the
equations
yeah i'm sure you can i know you can
yeah yeah i know you can but by
additional equations
and system equations
okay all right okay
yeah system equation okay
okay so fine so then that will be your
version of those equations up there
probably a little less elegant because
they're not hand drawn so to speak right
why is it taking so long
well
it's doing basically a compile to derive
the equations but that shouldn't be they
shouldn't take this time so i don't know
what yeah
i don't know what that is
okay there's some comments on our live
stream and we're gonna have to wrap soon
because i'm supposed to do another live
stream but okay so 2 000 equations
yeah and a lot of those are because
because it has an animation
and a lot of those equations has to do
with animation
and
and then there are a bunch of
uh
of alias uh
variables and so on that have equations
so so one thing when you do this
connection bit does the thing you always
complain about stephen that you have to
give names to things
uh-huh those names show up there and
they get eliminated at part of the
solving this one doesn't have a lot of
elimination taken care of right so
a lot of those a equals b basically
type equations are there trivial
equations basically yeah
well okay but i mean
okay let's just look at a couple of
these things on the
uh
live stream here
um
why is there no entity queue event is
expected to be inputs to functions
good question
trusty question one more time why is
there no entity queue why is there no
nothing which has a curried entity queue
that's a good point it's a good point
from nick there um it's a good point so
is something a valid entity yeah like
this
it's a good suggestion
we should have it
i mean it's sort of trivial but it's
sort of also useful for writing
functions like that good suggestion
should get added to the ild agenda
um
okay
complaints that the system model ide
looks like it's from 2000
you guys sound like me
in our meetings
we're refreshing it
crucial says they have a news unit
system prototype that's interesting okay
um just a
person on a live live stream here
um
uh
those are the words we we eventually
find out people send in
fascinating things to the function
repository or hopefully soon to the
packet repository
what is this
that is a
what is that that's parameter values
oh those things are quantity variables
so those things already are quantity
variables okay yeah
okay
um
let's see
yes various people here are commenting
parameter values already returns
quantity variables
oh there's a completely out-of-band
valid complaint somebody asking for 3d
voronoi
roger
okay i'm telling you
no i know i know i know the pitchforks
are coming out and we we're actually
i should have checked this version
let's just see i think charles is here
actually
charles 3d voronoi is it in this version
come on we got a show we got a show
that's
not yet sorry
okay but it is coming in this version
right
we are working on it
i would like to have an audible version
of an eye roll
um
comment that um uh yeah comments that
that it's often the case that even when
there's unit incompatibility it still
makes sense yeah it does for some things
but not for this modeling
stuff i think
um
okay
i think i need to run off because i am
supposed to do a different live stream
about history of science and technology
for those who are interested
um
and uh i think this was a good start
guys
uh you know there's i'm i'm i'm
certainly getting a sense of how these
things could fit together and i think
the results will be really nice
um and also i don't think this is
looking horrendously difficult but we'll
see
um
and uh
you know i mean i also do wonder about
whether
could the compiler generate modelica
code or does it not care could it be the
case that the llvm code generated by the
compiler becomes one of those what were
you calling from functional unit
something or other things
um fmu is primarily sort of an interface
spec of things that you need to respond
to to fit into a simulation system
okay
and so for instance i'm just going to
describe scenarios for which i think
that the compiler can can can know
something about and it would be probably
pretty useful
so
when you build a big new system let's
say you build a new jetliner
you you don't build all components in
one go so you want to mix both hardware
and software
and
so question is how do you wire them up
but not only that you might have
software components from different
vendors or different sort of companies
yeah i guess that needs to integrate so
how do they talk to each other and
that's kind of what the fmu's
deal with
right one thing by the way we haven't
addressed and i will need to go but but
is the linguistics
of you know because one of the things
that's pretty nice here is that you know
to get this double pendulum i can use
you know
that's pretty obvious name and i could
use it but you know i don't think it
would be
you know to get for your components to
get linguistics for your components
seems like a very finite project
for the components yeah
components there's thousands of them but
it's still yeah no it's it's only maybe
five i think somewhere between five and
seven thousand i don't know exactly
right it's fine you know that's what we
do there are however many 40 000 public
companies in the world you know we've
that's kind of par for the course easy
linguistics
the thing that you
okay so so there is sort of only fi you
know like coffee there's one coffee
molecule
yeah right
um
there is infinitely many electrical
motors
i understand i understand that's the
thing we have to address but by the way
there isn't just there are many things
which have one name but there are one
generic name take think about foods
michael is the big expert you know a
hamburger right you know there's a
generic hamburger and we have a way to
handle that in the case of food data
um
so maybe that okay so maybe we can do
something
i would think so i mean just
michael do you want to comment on so
could we have a gen do we have a generic
car there are many cars in the world
yeah it's a little bit different in the
example like for the food we have a
generic hamburger but this is a little
bit a hamburger
it's more or less all the same
as i say all the hamburgers that we
reasonably name a hamburger are more or
less the same maybe they have at most
variation effect or two but if we have a
micro motor and we have one from a
gigantius
uh ship
and we have five orders of magnitude
difference then some of the techniques
we utilized now of course will not apply
makes no sense to average or take means
or something right
i mean do you guys have a car
just to give you an example no no there
is no power over there
for instance say we have a 1990 honda
accord where we average over the four
six cylinder models the callers uh all
kinds of trims
like we we average at the level where
the variations are same is in 50
not within three orders of maintenance
we also have a project where we get the
generic refrigerator so we can do
estimates of things yeah but anyway i
need to go but this was a good start to
be continued
um
and uh look forward to that okay okay
thank you for now